millionaire Tillman fertitta's newest
Venture was approved on Wednesday and
promising all the bells and whistles for
its guests the project is proposed to be
43 stories tall and will include a
luxury hotel with approximately 2 400
rooms a casino a 2500 feet theater these
renderings show what the new resort will
look like which also promises high-end
dining a resort-style pool a 37 Thousand
Foot Spa and fitness center a wedding
chapel and Convention facilities for
Tata purchased a roughly six acre
property on Harman and Las Vegas
Boulevard during the summer for 270
million dollars a Travel Lodge Motel
souvenir shops and other businesses had
to vacate the premise by the end of
September on-site workers telling us
these structures were being prepared for
demolition very soon Fertitta is not a
newcomer to Las Vegas he owns the Golden
Nugget in downtown and many restaurants
under the laundry's brand like Morton's
Del Frisco the palm and Claim Jumper
just to name a few he is also a cousin
to the Fertitta brothers who run Station
Casino properties in support of the
parking reduction the applicant is
including a large taxi and ride share
area to help facilitate access to the
property
well it's unclear what the new resort
will be called or when construction will
begin County Commissioners were very
specific about construction coordination
since Formula One preps will soon get
underway and they stressed that is a
priority